[Music]
thank you
[Music]
on TV on Radio and on your smartphone
this is talk TV
[Music]
I love my father I love my brother I
love my family I will always do nothing
of what I've done in this book or
otherwise has ever been to any intention
to harm them or hurt them oh shut up
what a ridiculous thing to say every
single word of this book is designed to
harm and hurt his family I've just spent
four hours reading this trashathon today
it is unbelievable how much information
Harry now reveals in the most intrusive
invasion of Royal privacy ever and it's
him the prince of privacy the guy is
wanged on about it for decades it seems
how dare you invade my family's privacy
when I want to do it for Millions
it is breathtaking tonight on Piers
Morgan says that a it's good to be back
but Prince Harry stuns the Royals with
like I say the most extraordinarily
intrusive private Revelations and
personal attacks condemning the queen
Consul Camilla calling his father a
useless father boasting about Taliban
kills there's no decent member of the
Armed Forces ever does no detail is bad
it even reveals that William has been
circumcised
thanks Jordan isn't it
what does this mean for the future of
the British Monarchy
well Harry and Megan shocking claims
that racism rocked the royal family now
Harry says it was all just a terrible
misunderstanding
that's all they apologize
will they hand back their human rights
award
in the Oprah interview you accuse
members of your family of racism you
don't even well oh the British press
said that
right
yeah it wasn't the British press that
said that it was your wife Meghan Markle
you remember her she's the one that said
the Royals have been racist about the
skin color of your unborn baby and you
agreed I said it would be terribly
damaging if you ever revealed who had
done that well as Harry's Crusade gets
top billing and Blockbuster TV
interviews on both sides of the Atlantic
how much damage has he done to the
monarchy and to Britain or is it maybe
his own reputation that's now Beyond
repair
live from London this is Piers Morgan
uncensored well good ladies from London
welcome to Piers Morgan uncensored I
took two weeks off and all hell broke
loose but as usual most of the hell is
coming from Prince Harry's mouth he
moved to California rocking the
foundations of the British Monarchy it
was about three years ago they quit now
it seems like forever doesn't it uh the
claims he's made this week have
detonated a bomb but this weapons-grade
hypocrite has done nothing more than
reduce his own reputation to rubble and
after torching what's left of the
bridges back to his family he now begins
a new personal Journey we're told one
that ends with ridicule and irrelevance
the prince you fled Britain to protect
his family's privacy has laid bare every
Tory detail of his private life from
drug abuse to intimate conversations
with his father the king even at Prince
Philip's funeral
the daily fears for the security of his
family apparently has put a Target on
their backs now and on the backs of the
royal family and on his former military
colleagues with his stupid boasts about
killing 25 Taliban what he calls them
chess pieces and the be kind Ambassador
so earnestly invested in women's rights
brags about mocking a disabled matron at
his prep school he names her
she's called Pat she said she was greasy
and too ugly for him to feel horny think
about that woman tonight having to deal
with that in what will be one of the
biggest red books of the year how does
she feel if she's still around I don't
know how do her family feel about that
he also exposes how he lost his
virginity says he mounted some woman
behind a pub and she spanked him on his
ass
he checked that terminology with Meghan
Markle hasn't she just literally done a
polka series trying to eliminate sexiest
terminology from Men
oh dear Harry
the discarded son who just wants private
clear of the air talks with his family
if only he wasn't scared they'd be
leaked has now leaked everything and I
mean everything I read it all today it
is mind-blowing
most outragency of all Harry and Megan
allow claims to swallow about racism in
the royal family for almost two years
they made a six-hour documentary about
it they accepted a human rights award
last month for fighting structural
racism in the royal family all based on
what they told Oprah Winfrey but now
Harry's decided that apparently that's
not what they meant at all
in the Oprah interview you accuse
members of your family of racism you
don't even well of the British press
said that
right I did Megan ever mention the races
she said there were troubling comments
about what she was concerned about her
skin color right wouldn't you describe
that as essentially I wasn't not having
lived within that family the way the
British press reacted to that was fairly
typical neither of us believe that that
comment
or that experience
or that opinion was based in racism
I would like to apologize on behalf of
the British press actually because he is
an unbelievable village idiot and I
think it's all our fault honestly it's
not the fact that he was useless at
school and got no qualifications which
is why he's doing all this stupid stuff
it's the British press his fault we're
responsible for everything including his
Ginger hair and I'd like to apologize
for giving him Ginger hair it's awful
you should never have done it
but let me get this straight on a
serious point the racist British press
blamed for six hours straight of that
Netflix bilge for hounding Megan out of
our racist country
driven at the top by a racist royal
family
apparently it's the press That's to
blame
for saying that Meghan markle's claims
of racism were claims of racism
now this had consequences what they said
to Oprah Winfrey I was forced out of my
last job presenting Good Morning Britain
a job I really enjoyed because I said I
didn't believe these claims without firm
evidence
there wasn't any and now we get told it
wasn't racism exactly it's what I
suspected at the time do I get an
apology
to Sharon Osborne one of my guests
tonight does she get restored to her job
at the CBS show the talk because she got
fired for offering support on Twitter
for my right to my opinion because
apparently I'd said racist things it
turned out those racist things were not
believing Meghan markle's racism claims
now they say they didn't mean racism to
the Sharon get her job back
will they give back that award that they
got for the heroic battle against
structural racism in the royal family
now we know there was no racism
structural or otherwise
across three new interviews and 416
whining pages of his book spare me as I
call it Harry lambast the British press
and his family for colluding with the
British press his bitterness and bile
for Camilla the queen consort is
shocking this is the love of his
father's life who he Brands a dangerous
villain
how was she dangerous because of the
need for her to rehabilitate her image
that made her dangerous that made her
dangerous because of the connections
that she was forging within the British
press and there was
open willingness on both sides to trade
of information and with a family built
on hierarchy and with her on the way to
being Queen consort there was going to
be people or bodies left in the street
because of that
bodies left in the street there's a guy
who boasted about killing 25 Taliban
actual bodies that he left in the street
and then boasted about it which is now
enraged the entire Muslim world but
Camilla was apparently dangerous because
she forged relationships with the media
says the man who's pocketed over a
hundred million dollars by forging
relationships with media entities like
Netflix Spotify Oprah Winfrey James
Corden CBS ABC And So It Goes On
he says his brother the Prince of Wales
attacked him because he was riled by
reading stories and metabloids but also
that his brother placed those stories in
metabloids himself he slams a memoir by
Diana's Butler Paul Burrell as one man's
self-justifying self-centering version
of events my God the irony of this
from a man who's literally just produced
these single most self-justifying
centering self-centering version of
events imaginable
and if we want any more evidence of
Harry's complete loss of self-awareness
and utter delusion it's surely in that
claim that the book the book was never
intended to do any harm or hurt to his
family
you said you want your father and
brother back do you think that this book
is going to bring them back or they're
going to further divide you I have
thought about it long and hard and as
far as I see it the devoid couldn't be
greater
before this book but I genuinely believe
that if me and my family can reconcile
can put our differences behind us but
first there needs to be conversation and
accountability and if that doesn't
happen then that's very sad
compensation and accountability is that
a joke
is that a joke you're the one doing all
the attacking you're the bully you're
the one trashing your family in public
not the family that stayed silent
throughout this Onslaught that's been
going on now for several years
what's sad Harry is your public
self-destruction and the remorseless way
you've Savaged your own loved ones to
airbrush yourself
please don't make my final days of
misery King Charles said to Harry after
Prince Philip's Memorial we know that
because Harry's told us he's revealed
that most excruciatingly private
conversation with his father our new
king
imagine what he would have said if a
tabloid newspaper had revealed that
conversation it's disgusting and
I've done his privacy this proves what I
say about you more you're revolting yeah
maybe but what does it make you now
you've done exactly the same thing that
you've been ranting about for years
Harry and Megan just be clear
have sold their Royal souls for a life
as reality stars trading every private
cough and splutter for cash
the royal family has said nothing about
this volley of abuse it's maintained a
dignified silence which I think is a
correct response because without the
Royal gravitas without the titles Harry
and Megan well what are they they're
just another version of the Kardashians
they've gone for broke with this ladies
installment of the only way is Sussex
but we might finally be closing in
hopefully on the final episode
well joining me in the studios talk to
the presenter Sharon Osborne Vanity Fair
wrote that is Acadia from New York talk
TV's Tricia Goddard and Princess Diana's
former Butler Paul Burrell so a stellar
lineup to discuss all this Paul let me
start with you you like most people uh
get a kicking in the book he dismisses
you as self-serving writing a book just
to put one side of the of the point of
view I mean I had to laugh when I read
that this is by a guy who's literally
just done exactly that
yes it appears you knew my story at the
time I was being Trashed by everyone and
I went to the highest court in the land
and I had to survive I had to feed my
family I would everything I had was
taken away from me Harry's in a totally
different position he's an angry
petulant privileged prince who
constantly blames others for with no
accountability on his part his mother
would be absolutely appalled by don't
only Ant-Man himself he's undermining
his country his family the institution
which is the monarchy which his mother
was very proud of
um Beggar's belief I don't recognize the
young man that I grew up with I don't
recognize that man anymore I I just
don't know what's happened to him I
think he's lost the plot completely
Piers this book shouldn't be called sver
it should be called blame because he's
blaming everybody else but himself yeah
I completely agree and also I've never
seen an unhappier looking person who
constantly tells us how happy he is this
is not a happy man he's bitter bitter
bitter no and there seems to be no end
to the bitterness
no and you have to remember our dearly
Queen had to suffer this too before she
died because she also watched the Oprah
Winfrey interview and and thought what
on Earth is happening here why didn't
Harry come and talk to me about this so
she went to her grave actually not
knowing the truth with great distress
which Harry compounded in her final days
of her life well I think she I honestly
think the queen will be turning in a
grave reading all this stuff and reading
the fall out
um because not not only did that Oprah
Winfrey interview air literally a couple
of days after Philip was taken to
hospital and as we later know you know
died within several months but the book
has now come out within three months of
the queen dying and there is his
response to the death of our great
Monarch is within three months to do a
book which causes severe damage to the
institution that she represented so
magnificently for over 70 years
I
I totally agree and Piers you remember
those boys growing up you saw them grow
up you came to Canada Palace out in
those days Diana always had the final
word so I'm going to leave you with my
my words which I think Diana would be
saying right now she'd be saying to
Harry jumping up and down wants to be
noticed
Harry be quiet
now you do wonder who on Earth is having
that conversation with him what's going
to Trisha God I said Trisha you know you
were there on Good Morning Britain on
the day the uh well the morning after
the Oprah Winfrey interview air we had a
pretty Lively series of exchanges on
that show as you know I left Good
Morning Britain the next day because I
uh was asked to apologize for
disbelieving her claims of racism I said
I wanted to see evidence of this
so-called racism we now learn from
Harry's own mouth that they did not call
the royal family races after all uh so
I'm not quite sure why I had to leave my
job are you
yes
um because they actually didn't use the
words racist oh please and
would you like me to finish no I tell
you what I want to do Trisha before you
go any further I want to play you what
they said on Oprah then you can repeat
what you've just said let's watch this
and also concerns and conversations
about how dark his skin might be when
he's born
what about how dark your baby is going
to be
potentially and what that would mean or
look like what was that conversation
that conversation I'm never going to
share
um but at the time
at the time it was awkward I was a bit
shocked
and the end of that first hit with
Meghan Markle goes on to say that if the
baby was too dark that would be a
problem yes you may think that that I'm
afraid that is racism
the charge was racism against the royal
family at the time they produced no
evidence her version of events was
nearly two years after Harry's timeline
when this happened they've never named
The Royal member who said this stuff and
now we get told casually it's not racism
all right can you just play that again
because there must be something wrong at
my line I didn't hear either Harry or
Megan use the word racism I heard you
use it I saw the Press use it I didn't
actually hear them use the word and
that's what when we had that a robust
exchange of of words I think what I said
to you is that I do get fed up with
other people labeling white people
labeling what is and isn't racist to to
black people now if they'd actually use
the word racism
honestly this is utterly ridiculous so
what is racism I'll tell you what racism
is I'll tell you what racism
I know I'm white Morgan's about to
lecture a black woman about racism
I'm about to give you an example of
racism as a middle-aged white man who I
know is right the enemy to you because
you know let me tell you one example
racism is an example of racism would be
somebody expressing concern about the
skin color of a baby from a mixed race
marriage and when the when the
interviewer then says what if it was
darker that would be a problem yes you
may think that that is an example of
somebody expressing racism and that
became the headline and narrative for
the next two years after the interview
and for you to shamelessly sit there and
pretend that wasn't what they meant is
upper Village if there were more black
people in the media in the you know in
the Tabloid media they may have had the
opportunity to look into that and
explain it a little bit more I didn't
see it as racism I saw it and that's why
I got crossed when you you decided to
label it later I didn't decide to do
anything I well in that when we were
happy they literally confirmed Oprah
Winfrey but a member
attempts to talk about this in other
than headline news when I'm trying to
have a recent conversation I get shouted
over why is my experience or what black
people experience why do we have no
currency why uh they've literally had
front pages about the racist royal
family for two years how much more
nobody said it's Meghan Markle one has
no one has called the the royal family
racist I mean I I forgot I would say
it's built on built on the Commonwealth
and we already know Charles has had
problems you know they've talked about
the crown that Camilla may or may not
use and because the the history of one
of the Diamonds the Korean or diamonds
and what have you we know that the
royalty and many royal families around
the world were built on the backs of
slavery racism commonwealth countries
having good stolen or taken away from
that we know that unfortunately it's not
taught in school sorry
the history is racism
great respect to you you can't just keep
talking I'm allowed to ask questions
it's an interview right my question
you're not allowed to make statements
right without listening to what somebody
says Meghan Markle made a direct charge
supported by her husband that a member
of the royal family had expressed
concern about the potential skin color
of their baby which if it was too dark
would be a problem that is racism they
made a charge yes that's called racism
yeah if you think that if a baby's too
dark it's a problem that's called racism
sorry to have to lecture you about
racism I know I'm not allowed to as a
white man but actually that is an
example of racism
tell us about my history tell us about
the history of black people and what
rate what's that got to do with what
they said
because they didn't say it was racist
yes they did somebody else used that
word they stepped aside from using that
word I think very deliberately why did
they win an awards tell us about
unconsciously why do they tell us about
unconscious bias I'll tell you about
unconscious delusion which is they won
what does it mean I do the questions you
do the answering it's called an
interview show right it's before
Christmas they accepted an award for the
heroic heroic stand against the
structural racism of this royal family
based on what they told Oprah Winfrey
that was all a complete lie there was no
racism we now know they never meant to
say it was racism you're supporting them
that was never meant to be racism
queering the color of a baby from a
mixed race marriage and expressing
concern if it was gonna be too dark it's
not racism Trish you take me for a
complete mug it couldn't be a clearer
example of racism why deny it really
yeah no
so so am I right in thinking that you
know better than you you I have no idea
of what racism is I didn't say that I
didn't say that I said to you very
clearly sorry that you you sorry
what do you keep doing you keep putting
words into my mouth I'm not actually
saying and the viewers aren't stupid but
that's they can hear the conversation
with them they didn't use race you want
you want people to believe that actually
what she said Meghan Markle to Oprah
Winfrey supported by Harry does not
constitute racism and I'm afraid no I
said it's unconscious but I think you
are being deliberately either delusional
or disingenuous which one is it
you haven't explained what you
understand by unconscious bias so I'm
not quite sure you're not doing the
interview
no I don't care sorry we've now moved
from racism to unconscious bias right I
would like to move to unconscious or
conscious delusion because we all know
what she said to Oprah Winfrey we all
know that for the last two years the
royal family has been reeling from the
charge of being racist because one of
their senior members expressed concern
over the skin color of their unborn baby
and now we get told casually by Harry
clearly feeling a bit of remorse about
what's gone down here because I read the
whole book today this story doesn't
appear in the book this allegation of
racism isn't in there why where is it
gone why nor is he nor is the allegation
where Meghan Mark which is the other
thing I queried at the time before I had
to leave the building I also said where
is the proof that she went to somebody
at Buckingham Palace about her suicidal
thoughts and was told she couldn't get
help that's not in the book either
where's that gone and by the way what
happened to him at the same time when
his brother allegedly attacked him he
called his therapist who was on speed
dial why couldn't he do that for his
wife anyway these are ponderous
questions for you to think about
treasure I want to come back after the
break with Sharon and we're going to
talk to Sharon about particularly your
involvement in all this because you got
fired soon after I had to leave the
building over what turns out to be
non-racism
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
welcome back is still with Sean Osborne
and Cody nickel and joining us is the
former Royal Marine Ben McBean who
served in Afghanistan at the same time
as Harry and conservative MP and chair
of the defense select committee Tobias
Elwood and they're going to be talking
primarily about Harry's boast that he
killed 25 Taliban and called them chess
pieces something which was not only
enraged many of his former colleagues in
the armed forces but has also enraged
the pretty much the entire Muslim world
and who knows what repercussions may
come from that stupid boat so we still
come tonight Harry's truth has come a
long way and we'll be talking that in a
moment this first is Sharon let me just
pick up with you because you were
directly involved in all this it just
goes back to the Oprah Winfrey interview
and it's absolutely crystal clear in
that interview what Meghan Markle was
saying supported by Harry that someone
in the royal family had expressed
concern about The Unborn baby's skin
color and when probed by Oprah if what
if the if the skin color was too dark
that would be a problem Meghan Markle
said you may well deduce that yes right
that became the biggest story of all
these Revelations is that the family is
racist yes now we're supposed to believe
that's never what they intended Harry
says that Trisha Goddard says it there's
now a kind of whole revisionist thing
going on but this had real consequences
I didn't believe it at the time and I
had to leave my job but just believing
what was being said you then had to
leave your job because I was supporting
you because you supported my right to
free speech didn't agree with me right
um You had to go what do you feel about
this
um
it's all it's all just craziness going
around and around and he he's turned his
life and the Royal Family's life into a
soap opera it's like a really bad
distance I mean it's always been a soap
but I think what's different is he's
always been speculative soap opera right
you know part of the thing of the papers
he goes on and on and on and all these
interviews and the book I had to go
through all this the the Press are just
evil the devil he calls them all this
kind of stuff and yet the Press without
them without the press it wouldn't be a
royal family with other press doing
predominant I mean I remember the
courage of his wedding couldn't have
been more Universal phrase it was
beautiful he could barely bring himself
do we even acknowledge that right this
guy is so blindly hateful of the media
and British press in particular even
though he gets exactly the same coverage
in many parts of the world but when you
I mean I you haven't read the whole
thing I know but I have this is I've
never read anyone high profile talk
about their family like this all of them
his dad I know his stepmom I know
brother his sister-in-law the Queen's
dresser cops it yeah and there's a
really bad bit in here which I really
disliked which is very revealing about
his character where he trashes the
matron at love growth but he names us
Pat he calls her greasy and ugly didn't
make the boys horny right and says that
uh you know just carries on disparaging
her she had a disability with her spine
which made her she had to walk and he
used to mock her uh mock the way she
couldn't walk properly and he boasts
about this this is a guy who on his
website for Archie World their
Foundation describes his you know
standing for compassion
where's the compassion in any of this I
think well listen I'm just hearing you
picking up that story and you know I was
reporting on Harry when he was falling
in and out of nightclubs getting into
brawls with Paparazzi I mean I remember
speaking to the mother of one girl who
was dating he said he really just was
was impolite he was he was rude he
turned up drunk with sick on him they
didn't want him around their goal okay
and and that was understandable this is
clearly a man who feels that he's gone
through a metamorphosis a massive
reinvention and has come out on the
other side but what was so interesting I
felt about watching the interview with
Tom Bradley and I think Bradley did a
very robust very good job with him was
when he didn't mention the Metallica
racist allegations as he as he rightly
did but it was very clear that when
Harry was almost steered off into a Zone
where he wasn't comfortable or he
couldn't Channel his his therapy
speaking everything else he looked very
uncomfortable and I want to make just
one quick point on these races and
allegations I think this is very
important
when this turned into the biggest race
rail that this country has been in as
long as I can remember and the most
troubling storm for the royal family
Harrow Megan came out and made it clear
in a subsequent statement that they were
not talking about the queen or Prince
Philip because of course this witch
hunter said that would have been an
ample opportunity who said and by the
way this wasn't an allegation of charge
of racism it was one of unconscious bias
I think what's happened is he realized
too late because there's a report that
he tried to get the book withdrawn that
actually this was all going too far I
think I mean the fact that he hasn't
mentioned that in here the single most
explosive Revelation isn't in the book
nor is this supposed thing with the with
the palace denying Megan help for her
Suicidal Thoughts to make two very very
major emissions well they were the two
biggest they were the two biggest
Bombshells neither are in his book of
his life let me bring in Ben you
fantastic service to your country as a
royal marine and he was severely wounded
in the process thank you first of all
for your image service and it's great to
see you you know Harry you know you
fought alongside him in Afghanistan what
do you make of this
um yeah in particular the boasting about
killing 25 Taliban yeah I wasn't with
her in Afghanistan I was in a whole
different area
um
the 25
body count thing it's just it's
obviously him in context telling a story
and he mentioned a number but I think he
could have told the story very easily
without mentioning that number I don't
think it was boasting
um but at the same time if you say it
and give a number to it aren't you just
boasting I mean whichever way you're
trying to describe it he's just
literally saying what he's done which
was his job and thank God because that
was why we were able to get out of there
kind of thing because we called him and
it helped us out but I don't think
mention that number was wise would you
ever do that
no I mean the difference is before I
killed ten thousand men no one cares but
if he killed one everyone cares so it's
not wise for him to mention it it's a
bit like poking a bear as you walk past
right there's no point in
that's not doing any favors um so I
don't think he's boasting it but I just
I think there's he could have easily
have said what he said without
mentioning that number and on the
specific
um racism thing was your understanding
just as a member of the public
when you watched did you watch the Oprah
interview not a lot of it you saw the
you saw the clips yeah yeah yeah was
your on was your impression that they
were saying that someone had been racist
about the skin color of their child I'll
be honest it did come across that way a
bit
um and then obviously when the media
jumped in it it I didn't think I wonder
who was racist like because it kind of
come across that way um the thing is
just in my opinion
um it's almost like you're gonna go to
like a comedy show and the Comedian says
a joke that you don't like and you're
offend you're offended by it
um you can say that you're offended but
the comedian doesn't have to care so you
just kind of get mad kind of thing it
seems like that's like with his family
like he's obviously not happy with
certain things and he might have said it
to them and they may not they don't have
to care they don't have to respond or
apologize because his feelings get hurt
so then he's kind of moved away supposed
to be happy in America but he's not
clearly he's not happy is it no so then
he's kind of attacking his family by
revealing everything waiting for like an
apology but you're not gonna get one I
just think everyone defending him I just
think if it was their family
and someone was going on television
because they had some kind of profile
and was just doing this endlessly
trashing the family all of them I mean
it would you know you would I think most
people would cut off personally I I
still think Harry's great I think a lot
of troops do you can't take away what
he's done for this country more than no
no you can't
um but yes he's fought out with his
family but we don't need to now see all
of this because it's so funny then I
just think even though I love Harry's
great guy from what I know what I've
seen I don't have to support every move
that he makes including this one because
it's not very nice I think that's very
honest and I think you're quite right I
don't denigrate his service you know my
brother-in-law trained him at Sandhurst
he was a colonel in charge of William
and Harry uh their training there so
they were both very good very good young
soldiers nothing nothing I've never
denigrated that at all let's bring in
Tobias Elwood the conservative MP and
chair of the defense select committee to
boss you've actually worked with Harry
on the Invictus games which again is an
incredibly admirable thing the Invictus
games and I've I've always completely
supported it but when he said this stuff
about the Taliban you can see from the
reaction already around the Muslim world
the way it's been now latched on to by a
lot of Islamic fundamentalists and
preachers and so on this is going to
potentially cause huge security problems
not least I would think at an event like
the Invictus games
yeah I think you're right officially I
just wanted to stress the important
relationship there is between our
monarchy it goes back uh Millennia in
fact we saw that at the funeral for the
the queen and indeed we'll see that in
the coronation you know for the king
coming up that's a powerful bond between
all of our armed forces the three
services and I pay tribute to anybody
your brother and so forth Ben who's
there in the studio with you anybody
that steps forward uh to represent their
country uh and put where the uniform
that includes Prince Harry he did two
tours of Afghanistan and you're right
this huge Legacy the big thing that he
created the Invictus games has been
quite incredible but I think he was
ill-advised to talk about a kill count
we argue that we have the most
professional armed forces in the world
that's absolutely right that's not just
because of our combat Effectiveness it's
also how we conduct ourselves in the
aftermath of battle following the
genific conventions following the rules
of engagements how we deal with the
prisoners of War how we deal with the
injured who are actually served in Camp
Bastion as well in the hospital there
next to the you know the British
comrades and indeed how we deal with the
dead as well we don't go and join the
armed forces to kill people we go there
to defend we go there to uphold you know
democracy and the rule of law a
byproduct of that is the occasional
necessity use of lethal Force so for the
reasons as you've pointed out I think
this has caused difficulties not least
where we've left Afghanistan we've
seeded this back to the very people we
went into the defeat the taoban
themselves we have 40 million Afghans
that we still need to have a
relationship with we've got the Halo
trust for example a fantastic charity
that's doing mine clearance there all
these organizations still have to work
have a relationships I would say is that
extremists will take I would say that
his what he's said here and the way he's
expressed himself according them chess
pieces saying he killed 25 and so on as
a senior member of the royal family
which he remains I think that has I mean
the irony of this he has gone on about
security and protection for his family
never mind anybody else for the last two
years arguing he should have more
protection how does this kind of
statement in a book do anything but put
his own family at more risk it also puts
the royal family in totality I would say
at more risk from any lunatic
fundamentalist who wants to exact some
kind of Revenge for what he's said the
Invictus games and events like it might
become targets his own military you know
he might still have friends in the
military you know they they are now
walking around with a bigger Target on
the back because a senior member of the
royal family has come out boasting about
killing the talent man and how many he
killed and dehumanized them as chess
pieces yeah
I think it would be wise for Prince
Harry to provide clarification as to
what he meant there if you read The
Wider passes it's the only bit of the
book that I've read he clearly
understands what his mission was the
bigger picture as well what he was
fighting for but those particular lines
I understand it was written the book by
a ghost writer it was put in there to
sensationalize and as you've articulated
this can have serious ramifications not
least for the Invictus games which I
stress it was a pleasure to work with
Prince Harry in Toronto and indeed in
Sydney Sydney an important aspect of
Rehabilitation of those who have served
are serving but have been injured or
somehow you know need to be
rehabilitated I hope that continues I
hope this will not affect that important
creation that Prince Harry can be very
proud of to myself thank you very much
Sharon before we go to the break just
this is a correlation coming up in May
the coronation where King Charles will
be coronated Harry said he was a
terrible father couldn't handle being a
single parent father at all
um you know constant sniping at him in
the book he absolutely trashes Camilla
as a dangerous villain she's getting
crowned as well as the queen consort
she's a stepmother and he won't give a
clear no I'm not going to go and the
palace haven't said he won't be invited
I can't imagine in what world these two
Megan and Harry think they're going to
waltz in to the Westminster Abbey is it
well there is to watch a coronation the
two people are distracting a book there
will be
um an invitation I'm quite sure the
coronation because actually in this
situation Charles has to be magnanimous
in last night's interview Harry spoke
about the need for the royal family to
be unified and Charles knows that this
rift at the heart of the world but I
wouldn't trust them not to then do
another book another series but you know
what I think honestly if he comes to
this country in the next few months I
think he'll be booed I thought it was
booed last time well he was I mean a
little bit he was wrong man even by
Harry's brass neck down walking into the
scene of the coronation of two people
one in particular your father's wife the
queen Council who's about to be around a
wicked woman I mean it's just it's unto
me it's unconscionable you'd have the
brass I think it's possible that they
can go and it can be orchestrated in
such a way as was the Platinum Jubilee
celebrations where they were away from
his brother I don't think they should to
be anywhere near it I think and I don't
think they should be allowed to have
their Royal titles anymore bang don't
you want to do this you want to do this
Harry you don't get to keep the Duke
back goes everything goes anyway more
importantly Ben thank you great to see
you appreciate your service your country
proper hero this man good to have you on
the show thank you well still to come uh
frostbitten penises Ginger nuts and
Royal birthday wishes yeah there's more
of this
fan me
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
this is talk TV
[Music]
welcome back joining me our talk TV
contributor Esther cracker and political
journalist Avis and Tina plus editor at
large of a New York Post Sarah Nathan
and Dr Martin Luther King's niece are
leader King well welcome to all of what
a Stella lineup how are you all happy
New Year before we get any further let
me start with alvida King if I may Aveda
um we now learn today from Prince
Harry's interview with ITV actually that
there was never any intention in that
Oprah Winfrey interview to suggest that
the royal family have been racist now am
I living in Cloud Cuckoo Land or did I
hear actually the complete opposite in
that Oprah Winfrey interview
I think you heard exactly what you heard
and we've had this conversation about
race before so the big problem is it
seems as though uh England had had a
British queen before that was part
African her name was Beatrice now the
other point there's one race the human
race so there's no biracial or mixed
race that's just human beings that's the
scientific fact and the spiritual fact
so everybody needs to come off of this
arguing about the race issue and uh so
if somebody wants to know what
complexion the baby would be would be
pretty that's the name of the complexion
it doesn't matter the skin Hue because
that's one human race
your specific question is when when
Oprah Winfrey pushed Meghan Markle to
say was there concern about the color of
your unborn baby skin with a suggestion
that if it was too dark that would be a
problem and she agreed that surely is a
charge of racism it's nothing else right
it is it's a charge of racism and so I
think Harry and Megan need to read How
to Win Friends and Influence People I
wrote my own story many years ago and
showed it to my family first and my
friends and they said you can't write
that I said it's true well you can't
write it so I had God encounters a
therapy uh and relax and breathing
exercises and then I wrote a book called
King rules that became a bestseller so
Harry and Megan are traumatized they
need to be healed I'm traumatized by
Harry and Megan trauma
they're the ones doing all the attacking
and bullying for two years now
hurt people do hurtful things they're
making hundreds of millions of dollars
well money doesn't sell pain clearly not
really clearly because Harry is what
they're doing yeah but alvida clearly it
doesn't because Harry still looks
utterly miserable let me go to Sarah
Nathan um well what I'm saying
what the hell I'll come back to you to
Sarah Nathan about the the American
Anglers I've just done a column for the
New York Post
um you know basically just taking on
Harry the hypocrite frankly uh this
Prince of privacy who's now invaded
everyone's privacy when it suits him uh
what is the reaction though in America I
keep hearing conflicting reports that
people are with them they're against
them is it mixed what percentage do you
think of Americans are falling for this
Gus
I think hi by the way um I think what is
very interesting is that Americans in
general love emotions they love a
Redemption they love
um you know opening your guts on
national TV which is what they did on
Oprah and they I think they fall for
this a lot more than britsu and having
lived here for 10 years like I can
safely say that but I think what's
interesting now is we're starting to see
a little turnaround in the feelings
about Harry and Megan
um the sympathy that a lot of Americans
had is slightly dissipating what's
really interesting is that last week
Jimmy Kimmel did like the warring
princes and he he had two actors dressed
up as you know the musician Prince and
they were like meant to be William and
Harry and even the Bastion of Journalism
New York Times this afternoon
um are saying is this enough
um has he gone too far which you just
wouldn't normally hear right I mean I
don't think
really interesting let's bring in Avon
as to maybe sitting here patiently
watching this show Esther first of all I
mean this race thing is not a trivial
thing yeah these two branded the royal
family racist and gave specific examples
one of which was instantly discounted
the Archie hadn't been made a prince
because of his potential skin color and
the other story now has completely
Fallen apart with Harry saying we didn't
intend to suggest it was racist well
yeah and I think that that almost
gaslighting the British public because
they're saying it's the British tabloids
that said it and that implied it and
then we're all just about if we didn't
watch it with our own exactly and we
just we just went along with it like we
don't have brain cells and we can't see
and look I said that if someone said
that to me if I had a mixed ratio they
were concern about the currency
obviously you could say that's clearly
racist so I'm like why would you make
that why would you make that statement
and then come back and say oh actually
but they said it would be hugely
damaging to the person who said it if
they ever named them
putting aside your natural Love of All
Things Royal but this actually was a a
direct attack on the royal family which
reverberated around the world caused a
lot of problems particularly in America
particularly in the Commonwealth you
know Caribbean countries a lot of unrest
when they went on tour there as a result
of this suggestion they're a bunch of
races yeah I mean I don't understand the
dial back at all going back to
unconscious bias either I think that is
an objectively racist thing to say what
that family member allegedly said I
don't know why you dial back the other
accusation that he's leveled is that
Camilla has been in cahoots with the
Press he's been leaking and smearing
stories about Megan and himself is he
going to dial back on that too because
that's a really serious element by the
way I've known committer a long time I
know her well she's never once briefed
me about anything I don't believe she
ever does that it's Harry and Megan who
employed a team called Sunshine
something or other some PR them in
America to spin everything they got
their mate Omid scoby or rabies as I
call him who writes whatever they tell
him in his books right what's the
difference I'm gonna take a break when
they come back after break and get more
of your frothing thoughts probably my
[ __ ] thoughts and find out what's
next is there more of this can we take
any more of it spare me
spam me any more of this
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
just tweeted me the majority of the
public are behind Harry and Megan a
wonderful royal couple that is not true
the majority of the British public are
sick of them and they're not a wonderful
royal couple
so thank you for your Tweet but you're
completely wrong uh welcome back to it
but we're just talking about
circumcision and the break not something
I thought I'd discussed with the YouTube
ladies
um but we only know this because Harry
has revealed that he and William were
circumcised he can reveal what the hell
he likes and his frostbitten penis to
his circumcision whatever he wants but
revealing that the air to the throne is
circumcised I can't think of a more
intrusive thing for anyone to do to
William than what he's just done it's
his own brother the one who rails about
media intrusion I don't know about that
I think actually the fight was more
intrusive than the circumcision point I
think revealing I think revealing that
you punched your brother up I mean the
amount of times that my sister and I got
violent with each other I could cope
with my brother or both my brothers
especially my Army brother wants to do a
misery book called my dark early years
of Piers Morgan and uh but I wouldn't
mind I wouldn't mind that but if he's
like revealing secret details of my
genitalia I probably would have a
problem if I had if I had a sister and I
spoke about her nipple piercing for
instance far more intrusive than if we
got into a fight I do I do find the
circumcision facts mildly amusing though
I find it very amusing yeah I mean look
someone look there's no no doubt this is
highly entertaining in Parts it's
riveting it's incredibly intrusive right
I mean you just can't believe this will
be a number one bestseller good luck to
him he'll make millions but at what cost
at what cost he's blown it with his
entire family absolutely there's no
amount of money in the world that would
make me do this to my family yeah but do
you not think there's an argument that
maybe losing his mother at 12 and let me
finish I know that you're going to get
really upset no there isn't and in fact
there's one thing to do with this book
rather than buy it and feather his
greedy little Nest do what I'm gonna do
right now take spare and Chuck it where
it belongs in the bean take it away Tim
that's all from us tonight thank you Pat
whatever you're up to keep it
unsensitive and uncircumcised good night
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign